what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on with our x-men
Messiah Complex videos this is the birth
of the first mutant since the house of M
since everybody lost their powers so
again this is a pretty cool is a pretty
big deal and it is really really
exciting but in the last video was it
was really just like the one shot the
one that kind of set the stage for all
this stuff in this sense that you
basically just had like this mutant
being born basically the x-men were made
aware of it by cerebro and Charles
Xavier they were sent to Alaska to find
this kid only to find out that everybody
was aware of it and it seemed like the
x-men were the last people to the party
and so once we start to get back to them
basically returning to the Xavier
Institute and then the question becomes
who could possibly have taken it and the
initial response of the x-men is mr.
sinister it makes the most sense one
thing to bear in mind here for those of
you guys who were new to the x-men
mythos is that historically mr. sinister
has always been a villain who was
obsessed with genes specifically he was
obsessed with the genes of Cyclops in
Jean Grey but the idea was that he's
always trying to find a way to create
like the most powerful mutant ever or
like the perfect mutant now a lot of
that really stems from the fact that he
was transformed from Nathaniel Essex
into mr. sinister by the villain
apocalypse as it was really more of like
a personal vendetta to try to achieve
that goal than anything else but being
able to control a person of that kind of
power would grant him virtually a
virtual world domination he could
literally control the world because
there'd be nobody there that would be
able to stop him because this creation
would be so powerful and so this
obviously strikes the interests of mr.
sinister and that's why all the x-men
are really kind of panicking because if
mr. sinister has this child then one
it'll become corrupted undoubtedly by
the teachings of mr. sinister into
they'll probably never find it because
sinister is exceedingly good at keeping
himself hidden away from the world
through various bunkers and and
different things like that now the other
half of this is remember there's a lot
of things coming out of the x-men mythos
that we've covered so far that have led
to this rift between Cyclops and
Professor X and that's one of the
reasons why it's cool is because Cyclops
has always been like a solider of
Professor X he always did whatever
Professor X wanted him to do weather
suddenly Cyclops started learning all
these things like there was a hidden
x-men team that consisted of the third
Summers brother that Cyclops never knew
about and was never told about if
Cyclops his mind was wiped of all those
different memories and so because of
this Cyclops doesn't trust Xavier any
more because when he looks at him all he
sees is like lies and hidden truth after
the events of house of M wench calls
Xavier had basically vanished Emma Frost
and Cyclops had taken over leadership of
the x-men
because of all this distrust that's
going on when Charles Xavier came back
Cyclops and Emma Frost did not hand
control back over to Xavier so at this
point he's just a figurehead and so what
we end up finding out here again is that
because the acolytes work closely with
Sinister's Marauders the only real lead
the x-men have is to track down the
acolytes and in turn hope the acolytes
will lead them to the Marauders of mr.
sinister but it's cool because the
acolytes are not really an old-school
x-men team but basically the acolytes
are a group of people who always did
believe that magneto was right and at
this point they're just kind of waiting
for a magneto or a me really just kind
of hoping that he comes back or
something along those lines at the
moment Magneto's deep Howard at the time
this story's being written he actually
ends up getting his powers back but it
is cool because the acolytes have faced
off against the x-men time and time
again and so with the x-men tracking
these guys down the biggest thing they
have to realize and the one thing they
really take advantage of is the element
of surprise and moving quick and fast
because if they give the Acolytes time
to like marshal their forces don't
probably have a pretty lengthy fight
with the x-men they won't necessarily
win per se but they'll still have a
pretty interesting fight between the two
of them picking up with the Xavier
Institute is kind of interesting here
because the x-men team is met by the
arrival of Jimmy madrix multiple man and
Richter now Richter is an old-school
character he debuted back in like 1987
with x-factor issue number 17 I think it
was and he was a Louise Simonson and
Walter Simonson creation at least
assuming that my memory of when he shows
up is correct but he's basically part of
that era where Marvel had broken the
original x-men off of like the x-men
team and so you basically had x-factor
with Cyclops gene angel beast and Iceman
and Richter was actually a kid whose
father was killed by strife the clone of
cable from the future and of course his
powers to manipulate you know seismic
activity those manifested and ultimately
he was discovered rescued by x-factor
and basically became like one of the
early trainees for the team the issue
here is that after the end the events of
house of M he's one of a multitude of
mutants who had basically been deep
Howard now the multiple man with Jaimie
madrix he's kind of intriguing because
he leaves the newest generation of
x-factor that's one of things I want to
mention for a second is you had the
original x-factor which was basically
the original stanley jack kirby team
that was updated and given a more modern
line of stories by lewis and walter
Simonson after that you had x-factor
volume two or really like the second
iteration of the team which was
basically a government-sanctioned
superhero team which was led by like
valerie cooper and it was led
I Forge and then you have like the
newest it or at least the the newest
iteration of x-factor at the time this
story was written which was basically a
detective team they were like alias
investigations with Jessica Jones except
it was x-factor now the other half of
this is Lela Miller now Lela Villa is a
girl that Marvel never figured out what
to do with she was a character that was
created by Brian Michael Bendis I'm
pretty sure and it was basically just
this idea that like she knows things
like she understands things are
happening and like what that means is
just ambiguous it's a way it was really
a way for like various Marvel riders to
throw her into a story and say and this
is how we get out of the hole that we've
written
she's the definitive plot device for any
writer but the idea is that at this
point in time she's still very much
ambiguous she's still very really kind
of sparked the curiosity of a lot of
people and so all she really says is
like things are changing and and like
things are different now and basically
just saying like obvious things that
really serve no real purpose but still
what we end up doing is having Cyclops
split the group into two factions the
first is to have Richter travel to the
purifiers and basically become an
undercover operative and see what's
going on the other half is to send Jamie
mad rocks in Layla Miller to visit Forge
and see if he can figure out anything
about what's taking place and what else
happening it's ultimately what is I'm
happening is we switch over it's huge
Chelsea New York and this is cool
because we initially pick up with
Wolfsbane
now Wolfsbane of course is one of the
original New Mutants she's been around
for quite some time she was a Chris
Claremont creation and she was part of
the original New Mutants team she was
originally and got her name is I want to
say it's Sinclair but I can never
remember her first name but basically
she was one of the mutants that was
discovered by more McTaggart Wolfsbane
is kind of in like this off and on
character where she just kind of appears
and leaves and then appears and then
leaves and she really just kind of shows
up on whatever the story calls for but
in this instance she's actually here
invading this purifiers home base of
operations but the reason why is because
of course with her having like a
physical transformation that will
obviously invoke the curiosity of
anybody there purifiers immediately
track her down when they do it allows
for Richter to step in and start firing
shots it will stay not actually hitting
her but basically give off the
appearance that he's someone who's
anti-mutant and work his way into the
purifiers proper from there like we pick
up with Jaime mad rocks and Layla Miller
showing up at the residence of Forge now
we've talked about this before I just
want to kind of rehash this again for
those people who were new here you have
forge and then you have Tony Stark forge
is like real
really really good at building stuff
he's super good at like figuring out how
things work because that's his power his
power is to know how machines work to be
able to like reverse-engineer them to
pick them apart all that kind of good
stuff if he lost his powers he would be
no more capable of figuring out a Tony
Stark Iron Man armor then like you or me
and that's the difference between Tony
Stark and Forge now having said that the
reason why Jaime madrix is here
alongside Layla Miller is because what
Forge has discovered is that after the
events of house of M there were no more
mutants right I mean that's that's one
of the things that we talked about is
like the actions of the Scarlet Witch
and like deep powering the mutant
population on earth that had a
multiversal effect it's spread all
throughout the multiverse but ever since
this child's been born there are two
timelines that it basically sparked up
we're now there is essentially like
mutants rising to prominence in those
two different realities and so what
forge is done is he's basically created
a machine that will essentially allow
like Jimi mad rocks to send duplicates
through space and time into these
different realities and what he can do
is gather information on what these
realities are how these mutants came
into existence whether or not it all
stems back to like the main Marvel
Universe and these are branch off
universes whatever the case may be he
can gather all that information using
his investigation skills and then report
back now the actual duplicates
themselves and here's kind of the the
screwed up thing about it the duplicates
themselves won't actually come back but
we don't initially know this instead all
we know is Jaime madrix grabs his
duplicates and sends them into the
timestream
but Layla Miller runs up and grabs one
of them and gets thrown into the
alternate universe alongside the
duplicate of Jaime madrix and when the
main Jaime is like well we have to do
something we have to get her back
that's when Ford reveals it's a one-way
trip it was never designed to be a do
way a two-way trip they're duplicates
Jimi may draw a Jimmy man Josh can make
in you know almost any number of himself
the purpose of the duplicates was to go
into those universes gather that
information and then basically there was
a sub a subroutine or a kind of a
subconscious thought that was planted in
their minds of they have to kill
themselves and when they do all that
information will return back to the main
Jaime and he can basically report on
what he found
but with Layla Miller being thrown into
that alternate reality essentially
there's no way for her to get back now
ultimately jimmy manderach's just kind
of collapses when all that happens now
at this point we switch over to to
really the wolverine himself and this is
one of the things that I love about
Wolverines character right like
Wolverine makes his way of course he's
suffering like these extreme injuries
basically gets yanked into a hospital
they end up finding out that he
like walked right in front of an
ambulance and so they of course they
brought him to a local hospital and one
of the guys addresses the the local
nurse or doctor as Amelia and then
Wolverine pops pipes up and it's like
would that be a million vote because if
it is that's the person we're looking
for it immediately pops up when she
realizes that it's Wolverine now for
those of you guys who don't know Amelia
Voght is a character who debuted back in
the early nineties x-men explosion which
is to say marvel looking at like the
x-men line of stories that had just
risen in popularity just increasingly I
mean they had risen in popularity almost
exponentially ever since Chris Claremont
took over the stories in 1980 in 1975
and so in the early 1990s the x-men were
hugely popular but Amelia was basically
a character who was introduced who had
nursed Charles Xavier back to health
after he lost the use of his legs and
the result was that they had kind of
come together and they had had a
romantic relationship of sorts of course
that's all explained back in like
uncanny x-men number 300 I think but the
whole idea was that she's a character
who was there that Xavier was in love
with is somewhere along the line now in
terms of her powers in her history she
eventually joined the acolytes for hunt
but she has the ability to turn herself
and anything else into vapor and
basically like fly about and do whatever
that she wants to do but what this does
is it allows for the rest of the x-men
to respond as a million vote octa you
know acting his vapor she's the perfect
person for storm to dislike seize
control of and that's exactly what storm
does storm basically uses their powers
of the wind to kind of contain Amelia to
keep her under control and that's what
we end up finding out that what the
x-men are hunting for what they're
looking for is not just the Marauders
and not just mr. sinister they're
looking for the person who can lead them
to mr. sinister in the Marauders this
person of course basically being Exodus
now Exodus he is insane he's like a
ridiculously powerful telepath and
telekinetic
ah he's wildly powerful which means if
Exodus is involved in this then if the
x-men don't play things carefully they
will all die like Exodus is really
really amazing he's one of my favorite
characters out there and in in Marvel
Comics at least he was back then but
switching back over to a director who's
basically meeting with these purifiers
this is when we started to find out that
their work under William Stryker never
actually ended that where William
Stryker is dead that he's basically gone
now they continued on and not only do
they have a residence here in this
location they also have residences
everywhere even in New York and I'm
sorry even in Washington DC itself and
all these different warehouses are
stockpiled with
manner of weapons super high-caliber
weapons super technologically advanced
weapons like weapons of mass destruction
the whole nine yards they're basically
building a campaign for war they're
going to wage war against the entirety
of mutant conte and they're doing this
because someone somewhere has told them
that the birth of this new mutant will
lead to the ruin of all that it'll lead
to the destruction of all of humanity
across the world so the question is who
in the world is gonna stop it well with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comments explain make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
Rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like and I will
catch you all later peace
[Music]
you